The topic today is the Object Constraint Language, a part of UML.
So far when we've looked at UML we've been looking at diagrams. But
diagrams don't tell the whole story. There are places in the specifications and
the designs of your system where you need more details. And
that is what OCL was designed to provide to designers.
OCL is a language, it's not a programming language,
it's a specification language. It's declarative, it's strongly typed, and
allows you to specify the functional details of system properties.
OCL consists of a means to express constraints plus some collection classes.
And an ability to navigate around the various classes
of relationships in your diagrams. OCL's a mature technology is part,
an official part of UML and supported by various tools. Such as Rational Rose,
ArgoUML, Eclipse, Poseidon, Enterprise Architect and so on